you are listening to the hot breath
podcast I am your host comedian Joel
Byers and welcome to your weekly guide
to comedy mastery with desi piece of
professionalism you know that's uh that
makes a big difference in this game yeah
yeah podcast is a blues blue encore to
hundreds you like that it matches the
Magisters you Glee view blanket take
this I thought I'd say let me hold
somethin yeah and I got you some water
tips how you doing
this is 'fantasy this is our our water
sponsor this is a Georgia spring water
from the Blue Ridge Mountains they got
you taste the mountain in that that's
good stuff we collaborated on some
labels they do custom labels and stuff
so we out here see we doing big things
yeah it looks like it looked like we're
in a hospital before I wouldn't stole
this tree from well dude thanks for
doing this seriously I feel like with
this setup it's like we're in between
two ferns or between two joel's right
now I think I need to introduce the show
it's like hey y'all welcome to hot
breath podcast we're here with my guest
desi banks desi banks welcome to the hot
breath reverse hey welcome welcome
thanks for having I'm asking you thanks
for having me you are you are red hot
right now oh yeah yeah you're not you're
not you don't think you're even okay you
know but I haven't you know got to where
I want to be yet you know you know as
far as building to where I'm trying to
go yeah and hoping like um yeah a
hospital so they're having babies and
see we ain't made it yet we are just
doing interviews where we can there you
go I'm in here just stealing plants like
does he will understand cause you will
understand so you're clearly like how
old are you 25 25 yeah so dude yeah so
try see a pop in the cheer it's so young
yeah which I'm sure you hear is
so you could do whatever but I'm feel
like I'm 35 oh why so I don't know I
guess cuz I've been so into it you know
ever since I started yeah you know it's
2012 right yeah I don't fine yeah and
the first video you do goes viral crazy
what yeah how is that predestined I
don't know and you know when it happened
I was like wait a minute this is really
happening it and my friends like you
might we'll just keep going out yeah so
I just stay consistent I just kept going
and you know started building that you
know that fan base you know just been
going every sense man so all started
with the ATL talked ATL let us know what
was it I was talking about it you know
I'm saying somebody getting it to a
fight you know and I was telling about
to do you know I'm saying he running
into a fight but him being scared fight
anybody and it was like this Atlanta
talking on a slang type of thing you
know and then in the silence Lennie talk
something like that but it was like
video and it went viral man and you know
it was a good thing it had to be a good
sign yeah and it was like you know God
was like this is it man this this way
you gonna find your purpose that yeah
you know once I found that purpose man
it was everything that and that was
really just like in your living room
like this was not a big production
I wasn't alone yeah you like in front of
shade yeah yeah I was in my room my room
it just sparked my mind I said I'm gonna
do this boom and I did it and posted it
and maybe like 10 minutes later my phone
was just I was like it was crazy like
some app my friend tells me about you
know I'm like blowing up on it instantly
yeah and as I was being consistent
environment you know my fan base is
building up man and I was just like okay
wow I may be up to something
you know but like at that time though I
wasn't taking it as serious only because
I was in college and I was playing
sports there football wide receiver yeah
play receive it I was at Georgia State
my [ __ ] at the time
Moorhead though you sorry
I mean twice you gave it a shot I did
more here and then I transferred to
Georgia State and finished up hmm so
once I got the Georgia State that's when
I like really got back going to it you
know saying in 2015 when I graduated
okay I already start back doing because
you know in between once I was doing
football wasn't as focused on the social
media you know I'm saying like I want it
to be you know cuz of sports you think
you're gonna lead that's why I was like
you know I ain't worried about no social
media I'm gonna fail you know I just
knew that land of Falcons is gonna sign
me and then no but the Atlanta Panthers
you got the the path yeah Panthers yeah
it's a good consolation yeah well I was
wondering what was the second vine so
you probably post the first one you're
like oh I'm a I'm a prodigy and then to
the second one bomb I don't know I can't
even remember okay you delete the the
losses I I don't remember what my second
video was um I'm pretty sure I kept it
up there just because you know I'm
saying at that time cuz in the beginning
stages it's like you're just trying to
put stuff out there you just really
trying to find yourself yeah so you
don't know what the people like just yet
you just really got to be consistent at
doing something Danny okay you might did
been undone like ten videos and then you
can I really see how could he like these
wickets response you so now I gotta
start doing this got you know found that
niche with it so yeah it seems what's
impressive about your portfolio and it
is a portfolio like between IgE and
Facebook and YouTube
someone might blow up on one and they
may have a million followers on
Instagram and then Facebook they may
have like five thousand likes yeah all
platforms you're dominating it most
definitely that is that's very rare how
we've been able to achieve like such
notoriety across every platform see I
would say I would say because of the
that I do put out you know the stuff
that I put out I like to relate I like
to yeah getting the mic there yeah I
like the relationship is it's a showbiz
prepare myself but um I like to relate
to the people okay from young kids to
the older people you know I'm saying um
I do a lot of character work which
involved like family you know so I like
the involve like you know family you
know relationship problems family
problems
you know stuff that people went through
you know growing up so like my age
ranges from like I would say maybe like
14 you know but it's probably still some
younger people watch it but you know on
Facebook it's the older crowd yeah you
know so I know what they like and I know
what they want to see and it's like
Instagram I know I know
this would they want to see it's like
YouTube they like everything you know
I'm saying in Twitter it's like taking
like everything you know Facebook is
like really just for the old people
it's not too many young people that's on
like face I mean you have a few but
young people is more of Instagram okay
and it's like I kind of like found the
balance you know with that I would say
I'm still kind of probably not a hundred
percent but I'm at a good percentage of
you know would it
so you're maybe creating content you'll
only release on Facebook and stuff
you'll only release on Instagram
you won't like cross pollinate well now
I'm at a point where I make you fall
okay yeah you know I'm saying cuz
everybody likes the relationship
problems
everybody have a baby mama did they deal
with you know from the young to the
older everybody has the the bad child
the back everybody have a grandmother
everybody have a hunka are all
granddaddy
you know they could they do these things
that goes on in my video so now it's
like it's let you know it's leveled out
you know I'm saying where I can put it
on every platform but did that take time
to build into yeah
okay take some time cuz you know I would
say like literally like for real for
real
I really just maybe found my niche in
like you know people really start to
like get involved more I would say
probably what is it 2018 that I would
say the beginning of 2017 was really
when things really started to pick up
pick up
you know when I start to see like that
change big numbers uh-huh what was that
that you think once you know of course I
got with some kori actresses you know
I'm saying shots Abby Simone and Candis
and you know no no and just other people
that I work with and we all got that
chemistry you know we all connected well
you know I'm saying we we built that and
we stay consistent you know and the
people started love it
you know I'm saying hi my vision what I
do you don't say of course I want a
sitcom one day so yeah I try to put work
in with that so that people can I
visualize it as like a sitcom and you
know I get comments like oh my god I
can't wait to see this on TV and it's
like very inspiring to me so okay I'm
doing something good that the people
love so they can like really see it on
TV you know so I got something yeah you
know it's just only a matter of time you
know I'm saying it your team just
staying closing everybody believing that
it can happen not only me but them as
well and sharing the same yeah cuz it's
like you know I mean I can't do it by
myself you know so and it's not just
about you know for me it's for them to
could this can be something big for them
as well mm-hm
you know so that's how I look at and the
people they love it
you know I ate a part of day I probably
freak out if I came in with another
girlfriend or another baby mama wait a
minute this is not know you know yeah
because they they like what they see
that's like for example if Martin Branca
another girlfriend it's not Gina Gina
you know so that's it's at a point I
feel like is it don't got they don't
something today and people love it and
people love it on social media and I'm
sure you've been in the room
with very influential people now and
powerful people and people almost the
invisible hand of entertainment and
where the tide is headed do you even
think TV is the way to go huh man social
media is being so strong man and I want
to say TV but so many people is on his
phone yeah all the time timeout with
Netflix with you two with even got the
stuff like HBO and stars they got apps
for that name yes so it's like I can
still just watch it on their phones like
I don't know it's like cuz I want to
make it to the TV okay well maybe you
need to be turned on the TV don't be all
your phone so but I don't know man
social media is becoming a real big
impact to the world it's becoming too
big man yeah you know I'm not saying
it's a bad thing but I mean it that's
where it goes I mean it's fine I mean
I'm not gonna complain but cuz that's I
mean you're already established there
yeah it's like going to TV it's almost
like okay
now you gotta heard them to this as
opposed to some like they're already
invested like YouTube is almost it is a
TV channel is this hell yeah especially
with the amount of eyeballs you're
getting is more than yeah a lot of demos
yeah what is there something just to
that you just love Martin and you think
the Desi Bank show is like a Martin so
you just want to see it on TV just from
a dream like oh you know like a big
thing to like yeah me growing up
watching Martin and being inspired by
his shows and you know Eddie Murphy
being my favorite actor you know I'm
saying I want to be able to do some of
the things that they did as well but in
my way not saying I want to be like them
but in a desi way yeah I'm saying so
yeah and this yeah man to get these
numbers you're getting a thing you've
harped on a couple times is consistency
yeah that's the test go into more detail
on that consistent I'm some more like
putting out videos I mean you can't like
you know in the beginning stages you
just can't put like one video out a week
and just think that's it mmm you know
I'm saying you gotta put like in the
beginning like when it was 15-second
videos like literally I probably posted
like 4 videos a day
a day a day okay you know until I got to
a point okay now I can slow round now
they see me a few times so now I can
drop down to two videos a day and you
know here come one-minute video so now
it's like okay now I got one minute
videos now I can do one video a day or
two to three videos a week you know I
don't have to put too much pressure on
myself down to that much yeah for a day
to two a week you know I'm saying oh
okay you know what she done built that
you know once she doesn't get to a point
where you cannot okay cool now you have
the time to focus on other you focus on
this but also focus on other things as
well as far as like you know building on
the outside of your brand you know I'm
saying doing things are gonna be able to
take you to another level outside of
social media what's where it's kind of
things like um I would say like acting
you know I'm saying I'm going to acting
classes and stand up you know being on
stages and preparing myself for things
like that because that is gonna be able
to give you a whole nother type of you
know I look at social media now as it's
like your foundation is your brand and
it's like now okay what else you gonna
do you're just gonna do social media or
you gonna where are you gonna take it
talents to you know and so with this
platform when they see me on TV now
these music people they're gonna go
watch me on TV you know and it's gonna
make you look like okay now it's gonna
be an inspiring set of people like hey
he started from here now he's there yeah
you know I'm saying like look at that
that's why I want to touch that TV
platform you know pinna sitcom TV shows
and being in movies and stuff like that
you know stand up you know and stuff
like that so yeah man that's the
leverages and those followers like yes
you see Wilding out everybody's
phenomics they all have followers that's
the resume yeah yeah so it's phenomenal
bro is you know once you get to that
level man and it's like once you get to
the TV level it's like now okay you dare
but now it's not on you now now you
gotta keep your foot in that door now
you know I'm saying you
to stay consistent and working so I feel
I look like yes so she meet her right
now I feel like it's a stepping stone
it's preparing you for sometimes because
once you get to that level you'll work
that they gotta be on time ten boom
yes and you got to be that much more
consistent man yeah and yeah a lot of
that a lot of consistent can come from
organizations most definitely so how
does organization play into how you move
I would say focus and you know having
the correct team you know around you to
keep you at a level of you know time
trying to get to that point you know of
course I have a agent acting agent Gaad
should give me these opportunities as
far as going to need audition audition
rooms anchor you know meeting these
directors being on set with you know
major producers and directors and you
know stuff like that that's gonna be
able to elevate me to that level but I
would say man getting to the level you
gotta have a team you can't do it by
yourself boom
can't do it by yourself man and it can
be really tough really really tough but
doing about it you know I'm sorry the
social media part you probably have to
do that by yourself to build it up to
build it up you know and then once you
get to a point then that's when somebody
who come say okay he done bit so maybe
grab them up you know let me help him
out you know cuz something you gotta
help yourself first before somebody else
help you you know a lot of people think
people just gonna come and just come on
man
but you got to put your work in it man
they gotta be able to trust didn't know
what they got like the person that they
they know digging he don't work hard you
know they know they're gonna stay
consistent they know they're gonna do
these things so you know then best-in
but you know maybe you get a mindset
like you know hey I don't build this now
I can do the business and I can bring my
team in it you know I don't have to
worry about you know that's why I say
shout outs are like Issa Rae you know
yeah you know I look at people like
they're like you know she didn't wait on
nobody
you know because social media give you a
point like you don't have to wait on
nobody
you don't you could do everything
yourself you know I'm saying so it's you
know there's a lot that goes in
stuff and as a comedian specifically
that's where like all comedians are like
oh man how to have a viral yeah how do I
blow up what am I doing wrong
like what are some what are some common
mistakes you're seeing comics make in
the social media world it's the
consistency man that's the x-factor
because you know like you say like for
you
you know with once you as you keep going
you're gonna find you don't find a niche
but the thing is to keep going though
said I feel well first you gotta love it
yes if you love it you're gonna keep
going you're gonna I love this like I
don't care what the results I get I
don't care I'm gonna keep going no
matter what I love doing this and as you
keep going you're gonna find out you're
gonna find out what the world been
missing like you're gonna find that
thing the world love you know cuz it
took me some time to really like find my
niche like I spit upon like like what
can I do consistently and I don't have
to do other stuff that's like weird and
awkward you know I'm saying consistency
that the people is gonna love and people
you know they worry they're so worried
about going viral but to be honest is
really they need to worry about finding
that niche you know find that niche find
out what you'd like to do and not what
the people like that's what they
gravitated towards yeah yeah yeah cuz a
lot of your videos that you thought
we're gonna go viral
a delt just the opposite right stop
until my bro is so crazy and now I'm
like I just when I post video I mean of
course I wanted to do good but it's not
me is up to the people is with the
people like but I get is like I done
done a few things to know what they like
so that's kind of advantage that I do
kind of have but you gotta keep going to
like really find that niche though
mm-hmm you know so when did you feel
like was it was it a repost or like what
what took you from Oh can't being
consistent I'm hammering it out until
you're like oh I found it when I felt
when I like it when I say I when I start
doing stuff with other people like be
Samoan and canned isn't that's when it
took off I'll start to see like the team
yeah
I couldn't duck it to that level is like
you can't do it by yourself you know I
mean I'm naturally funny you know but
once you found that team and it's like
you find yourself you find a lot of
stuff that's you know it's it's like you
find the thing that God got for you you
know Jan so which is no more dick there
you go
I'm walking to my calling that took off
yeah that's you know and it so crazy
when I said that it just came to my mind
it was a problem the whole thing was
improv oh wow yeah I think we said ID
like we wouldn't do and she came in
already know you know I was just
clicking I was like no more and it's so
crazy it's so crazy because in my mind
it was like don't say that say that and
before you know I'm saying posted it no
it was crazy I like but we had probably
had like 300 come isn't like six minutes
I was like jumped onto yes um he
reposted he reposted another video that
we did as well but yeah you know and
this is it was crazy bras I was like and
that's been like a thing like every time
somebody see me now they might be like
no more stuff like that people don't
it's like you don't write those things
that you can't write that down right
those moments like you know even like
with Martin I feel like you know
something stuff with empar like for
example like you know what you're wrong
he didn't wrap I'm pretty sure he didn't
write it was stuff like that that sticks
I don't think you can write those things
you can't write that stuff man he's just
meant to be is this miss explain natural
brows oh no what is the most time you
spent on an Instagram video cuz I've
played around a little bit where it's
like well it's a 60 second sketch we'll
knock that out and it's like three hours
later like wait what yeah like it's a
production what's the most time you
spent on these video like two hours bro
oh yeah you're like - I'm talking about
like really trying to get the correct
take in mm-hmm you know this person got
answered just gotta edit it down I don't
like to take that out but that's like
what couldn't see now I kind of like
made it a little easier for myself see
now what I do now is to not even work so
hard I just we shoot everything that I
you know I write it down and we'll shoot
everything no cuts no nothing we just we
go back and forth right here so only
thing that I be cutting this the end in
the beginning and a video is done I have
to worry about cutting it we're gonna
get this tape right here and that's
gonna be it and I was like you know so
cuz in the beginning I was like okay
this is a lot of cutting I'm getting
tired of cutting stuff I need to make it
simple and be consistent with that you
know oh man you'll get tired of it so
yes I got I just shoot it out and you
know you know found that way so yeah and
you found the Sustainable that's a good
thing with consider is if it's stressful
it's not sustainable isn't that you know
- oh yeah yeah it is show and you know
they see it so yeah that's what I've
learned I went through a phase now I'm
just I'm all-in on hot breath I got just
I'm just building this yeah as like a
platform
yeah and that's that's my new kind of
that's my new motivation that's where
I'm gonna be drawing fans in most I went
through a phase on like Joel buyers
comedy where I'm like I'm gonna be
political unless you sketches and I'm
gonna have comments every day about
what's happening in the news man I did
about three of like just looking at the
camera things and the cutting and I'm
like no
nobody's found it through listening to
people that is most of my feedback is
coming from the podcast and all they
learned from it and the cool guests I
get on here so I'm like oh like you said
listening to your followers what do they
want okay give them flood them with that
let it
I'm telling you yes make them fall in
love with it you know
inspire them with it man and connect
with them like what I like saying the
most is when I see comments like when
people say oh I went through that man I
know exactly that feeling you know and
oh I miss my grandmother I wish my
grandmother was still living it's like
you know I'm touching them through
real-life situations and that's like
what my comedy is about I like to stay
relatable cuz to be I feel like
everybody then went through somewhat of
the same stuff it's like growing up and
like dealing with like relationship
problem baby mama problems and you know
it is all light so what I do you know
even though I have a baby mama like
you're my video you know is it's nothing
negative you know about the situations
in it's like it's a lot of people out
here you know that don't deal with a
baby mama you know I'm saying it certain
extent but it's like I even see coming
so I hear me call my baby mama man you
know since it like you know you never
know what could that can lead up to and
they might be watching the video
together even though they didn't like
each other at the moment that video my
connector may be like look at this why
we can't be like this you can bring
people together you know so keeping it
focused on the family yeah you know man
and you know and just bringing that
peace is never it is it's not really
ever no negative and none of my videos I
don't pour the negativity so that's
almost something you put your content
through is like a filter as like is this
is positive is this about yeah it has it
has to have definitely gotta connect
okay
it has to connect in a positive light
that the people are loved
you know it has to and it seems what
you've referred to as it has to connect
with you first
most deafness so it's that's so
interesting about social media it's
almost like the more personal the more
universal most definite interesting most
definitely and most definitely yeah
that's that's the a bit key yeah
so if you create something and you're
not that into it but you create
something to be viral but you don't care
the audience isn't gonna care okay now
the exact opposite
now create what you want to see mos def
see you got it you got to create you
gotta fill it in your good day okay I
like this like when I do my videos when
we do takes it's like okay that's the
one mm-hmm you know I feel like that's
the one so I'm gonna put this out you
know and we're gonna get the university
respond to it you know so once you feel
that connect okay that's good then you
put that out you know I don't I don't
try to outdo my other video cuz
sometimes you know I can find one then I
try to do another taking this like I try
to outdo that one but really that was
the one you know
and you know in the back your mind yeah
[Music]
and usually go with that one that you
say you know so yeah yeah and thinking
of this connection we're always like
yeah I'll just do it my followers want
but it seems like I'm social media
there's also algorithms at play here oh
yeah
so what is it what's what's that world
about it's like you with my rhythm of
course you got to know when to post my
times I like prime time I post around it
depends on today so crazy because I'm on
Sundays I post around bout 4:35 midday
and do you schedule your post like do
you put him into like a scheduler and Oh
put him up ahead of time you know no
[ __ ] content count now if you heard
of people doing that you know no no no
but doing a week I post around 7:15 p.m.
doing a week Saturdays I post at 11:30
any morning 11:15 up at 3:00 in the
morning not an even inputs at ER days
everybody is out you know
[Music]
and yeah you know the acronym is really
based on like your consisted of poster
you know it very it goes up and down you
know with the amount of views that you
get and the likes and the the you know
the comments and you know they engage
that you get with your fans you know
that it just plays that balance but
BIGBANG is known when the post and is
that through like analytics yeah let it
show you okay they tell you the best
time the post but is like I found even
without their any analytics I found the
best time for me that's that's good and
like it's been consistent for me which
is 715 you know for the people you know
so how did you find that number for
yourself are you tracking are you
keeping notes of like okay I posted a
six this week I posted it at 6 p.m. on
Sunday did okay oh this week I posted at
7 did even better definitely just like
yeah uh-huh
and it was at a point where I was
posting at like 8:30 9:00 which it was
cool but it would be like some people
will probably be all some people to be
sleep you know that's - probably not not
good so I dropped down to 715 it's like
it's like that they're right they're
right you know the right time of the day
you know some people just got off work
you know some people may be laying in
the bed some people I don't you know is
it right there right I feel like I said
right stead sweet spot uh-huh you know
for me you know and then is really
you're just some water - yeah it's
really even that fountas water it's
really knowing your fans age range as
well okay you know so my biggest range I
would say it's from like 21 tonight 25
is this Instagram yeah okay but I you
know I still have like 30 you know but
like that big is it's probably like 21
to 25 that's like my
biggest range and knowing that there are
young people you know I'm saying so it's
like that 7:15 is like this thing and
it's a different I think that's another
good note is knowing who your audience
is so your audience maybe 7:15 my
audience may be comedians that are out
at a show at 9:00 p.m. or exactly just
knowing when that is yeah and maybe a
weekend evening may be a good time to
post the video as maybe a Tuesday
morning is better to post like an image
or something like that to mode FAC
uh-huh with images as you said it images
I post around bout I would say 11:00 in
the morning
12:00 you know those good for images you
know just some make it just roll you
know and just pop off you know
especially in the morning you know in
the morning it did you know where the
video is it may be vain China and there
may be it worked
yeah you know if it's a picture it's a
coma you know but it might be a work
that came
listen to it came late I didn't say i
watch this later and when I get off or
something you know something like that
so yeah what about Facebook like this is
like we're just um on Instagram what
about Facebook is design that I when I
post some more Instagram I posted I post
I got actually posted on Twitter first
huh yeah and you know it's the crazy I
found the thing to see Twitter's like my
test
you know I posted on Twitter first and
if I see Twitter is doing growing
Twitter okay I know exactly what's going
on Instagram I know is that cool just
gonna Facebook I know exactly what's
gonna do on YouTube so if you don't do
good on it if it only give me my good
filament on Twitter I don't post it so
it's like it's like a cheat sheet
uh-huh you know I'm saying like that's
what kind of like keep me safe
you know I posted on Twitter first okay
if it's say for example like 50 retweets
and 67 minutes that's phenomenal on my
Twitter page you know so if I see this
okay it's gonna be a good video I'm not
even gonna worry about Facebook I was
gonna do good you know I'm saying
if it's like 15 retweets in six minutes
you know but he's like SEC I mean you
know that's nice yeah a beta test yeah
testing if it's worth going most
definite to the sky with most definitely
so can this get off the runway but we
throw it off the cliff there you go yeah
twitter is like that that cheat sheet
for me tonight you know before I post
anything so how important are captions
and all that game always be yeah cuz
there look at that caption before they
even watch the video interesting yeah so
if you gotta be it got a pop to the
people it has to pop to the people so
yeah how do you make it pop to the
people um this is a penal what you
saying I would I would say for okay baby
mom video um when you're a baby mama
steer your money or it Stokey were you
when your baby mama whoop your son oh
when your baby it just you know it can't
just be when you baby mama are you
trippin it's good I can take the D is
those key words that make him go watch
uh-huh you know
gotcha so once they captured pop okay
but watch it now yeah it's gotta be
concise I see some people do like
paragraphs dude on the follow yeah it
depends on the father I mean I've been
straight straight up with my you know
straight up simple well who knows you
know so but with a with the content not
limit content length Instagram 60
seconds what length of video do you find
works for like a Facebook cuz that's got
a matter to it like Facebook it's a
longer video so they may be more likely
to consume three minutes while on
YouTube they may consume 20 mm-hmm is
Facebook like a smaller window of time
have you found out Facebook is it can be
a minute or more well like what
what the followers like what will they
usually there's got to be a sweet spot
with even the link to the content right
I've just been a minute I have two
minutes on face yeah whatever I post on
Twitter YouTube Instagram it's not a
minute I know they want more but it's
like you get more awesome if they're
doing longer stuff like you know being
on TV or just a I'm gonna see more like
I want to see you in a movie man like
you want to see you they want to see you
do more yeah but it's like I can do
these right now and to like okay I feel
like they want to see more but I feel
like when there's more time it's like
you got to do more if it makes sense
like in promoting it or it's like like
what a minute okay once they laugh at
that minute haha what do you got next me
I gotta be funny too and then next bin
you gotta be funny too yeah okay
sketches longer it's gotta be yeah I
just feel like a minute I'm it's good
for the people right now especially
attention spans like it has to be funny
funny funny keep going you know what not
saying I can't do but when I'm doing
that live I want to be like doing my
sitcom stuff and doing ice get you know
more sketch stuff except exciting stuff
and you know stuff like that I guess I
was just thinking for hot breath and how
I'll post like interview clips yeah you
know an Instagram I'll post minute
snippets of stuff but on Facebook I may
do a three to five minutes so didn't
clip moto fee but that's a little easier
to just snip that as opposed to writing
a seven-minute sketch it's a completely
so I guess I was thinking in those terms
yeah of just how it can apply your
knowledge to helping build hot breath do
you have any insight for me brother
banks do you have any insight for me OC
on any side that can be different but
it's still good that you picture your
many Clips you know as far as like being
on Instagram you do like you know have a
link in your bio yeah
to the full yes I suppose the full
interview on YouTube yeah and I'll clip
it up for Instagram and then I've been
doing clips for like LinkedIn and
Facebook longer ones but maybe a minute
is all they really care about so I don't
think I don't know if Instagram would
get extra time only because of Facebook
and they like connect it with each other
it's like yeah once you give Instagram
this mother much time Facebook that
might kind of like pull some people from
Facebook and break them over to
Instagram because Instagram is like
really is a big thing it's really big
out of all of them that's the one that
you yeah I think it's very interesting
but you know it's crazy it's on Facebook
they have some interesting stories I
like to like watch and look at it's a
lot of stuff that's owner but it's more
with this stuff it's more like real life
things that's happening mmm you know
yeah it's the whole Facebook thing it's
like a like a news yeah that's what's
gonna say Facebook is more like a news
channel it was more like your
entertainment yeah you know okay that's
an interesting way to even look at
cutting up interviews to where maybe
more entertaining clips are on Instagram
and the formative ones are on Facebook
yeah that's what I wore it kind of
sparked me that kind of helped me out
yeah yeah I even think about it like
that yeah yeah cuz I was I saw on your
like YouTube the desi banks show that's
like how long is that be a 20 episode
get it the short film the short film
yeah it's like 23 minutes so did you
over sit calmly you know and the
commercials is the 30 thinking about it
all because that's that's income yeah
yeah and I did that I did that I did
that were like two years ago
you tell Nutty Professor is your
favorite movie yeah
that's the jam right yes doing all the
character and is like when I was doing
I'm like this Eddie Murphy went through
man I'm like I feel you know I might not
been on the Eddie Murphy level but I'm
like I can do it you do know when you
know you know so one's a big old budget
coming
you got some big people one I like and
that is you know because even that
looked legit like I'm sure it was good
very well that was good yeah I have fun
shooting it you know so how important is
production quality in a social media
post always be you gotta be clear he
can't shoot no Andrew it it's not gonna
work
take that Android isn't that we're
watching this on Android just shut it
off cuz your whole life is shut down
please don't I'm sorry
you know Android II it's not a no it's
just not built III phones are built for
that yeah it is for shooting and
anything it is it is androids are built
for suckers I guess you know I have an
Android I got a I got a galaxy s6
actually these sponsors that come
through man I need I need an Apple
sponsor eventually right yeah it's one
step at a time
yeah patience because if you can and
that's something important for like a
comedian that maybe is posting sketches
and it is on an Android as opposed to an
actual like camera which now people are
shooting camera shoots gets on like red
cams and stuff like yeah DSLR is like
it's that professional now yeah it's
phenomenal but it's important I think
for somebody starting out or just on the
hustle and all they have is an Android
still don't let that stop you yeah cuz
you never know baby I know as a camera
but you probably be funny as you know
I'm saying don't worry about that you
know I'm just saying we're just talking
about the quality exactly you know use
what you got yeah don't this believe if
you can do more with less just get more
most definitely do everything else
deficit do I like that quote oh I like
that
yeah you can do more with less when you
get more you can do everything most
definite more do anything yeah yeah
that's the - that's what he said yeah
that's what I loved him watching
I watched the Desi Banks Show and out
cuz I knew you were a fan of Eddie
Murphy and Martin and like Mike Epps and
all this and they see in
production I'm like yo like I knew who
you were before before doing this
interview but I always like in-depth
research my guests and when I started
looking into you I was like oh whoa this
isn't just somebody who's funny on
Instagram this is someone who has
actually built a platform almost really
like a media company is what you've done
mm-hmm in a very short amount of time
mmm yeah is that what you're seeing in
the long term Tyler Perry studios type
oh man I would love that that you see
that's very inspiring I can see it I can
I can see it you know I can see it I can
see it you know
but like I said with stuff like that I'm
pretty sure like you know choppy yeah
like a job man
and you gotta have that you know and God
let's not forget about you know and no
more dick nobody keep thinking no more
yeah but yeah yeah everybody gotta be
doing a job you don't need so much a
person can do yeah by yourself because
it's so many talented people that's out
there but it's like they need that extra
help man like you need the X you got it
you need that right I don't care like
you need that man you need that team you
need them people you need that what
people doing their part
you know everybody doing that part what
are some tips for comedians like new and
old because everybody you're almost
doing the reverse you you blew up on
social media and now you're getting into
the stand up game has a lot of us you
know I've been doing comedy little were
eight and a half years now I've been
working at getting good extend up and
now I'm like okay how can I build a
following how can I let people know
about this what are some tips you have
for comics in that space um I would you
know from my end point social media is
totally different from the stage there's
a whole different ballgame it's just
it's nothing to play with I would say
but if you like if you funny if you feel
like you
you know you can find a niche on the
stage and not just be doing it because
somebody else said oh you got this
amount of following but you gotta do
this you gotta want to do it you got to
be something that you really wanna do
man because it's only one take on that
stage can't cut net now you can't cut it
you can't say okay let's do it again no
they look at you like what preacher you
supposed to be a professional right
right right
you know but you gotta know the gifts
and talent that God has blessed you with
wants to go onto that stage now you know
yeah you know what's the worst you've
bombed how long you been doing stand-up
six months have you been booed yet I
have people walked out was the worst
bomb and that's my ass like I think
because of my approach of what I see it
and they're like kind of messed up
everything from the beginning and I was
like oh I didn't like that remember what
you said I think I was talking about
where I was in a not so good way and
they wasn't feeling it they wasn't
feeling it Oh like the actual room yeah
you're making fun of the room yeah yeah
that's a good way to turn people off
yeah and I like even if it's 12 people
and you're making fun of the 12 people
it's like okay now yeah and I was like I
learned from Edo you know yes you learn
from EMA is good to go through those
type of situations because it's like
really okay it's like God testing you do
you want to do this cuz this is part of
this you know and it's like okay okay
okay I don't been through it you know I
know how I feel how did the choir feel
and I know when people not laughing in
that interest I know them feeling so
it's like huh that's fine just go find
what works
you know just Catina
from that cuz I feel like a lot of the
Great's then been through situations
like that where everybody I feel like we
don't have a story to tell with that I
mean if it's just that easy for you I
mean like gang right that's the
benchmark question on this podcast I
asked every comic on here
what's your booze story yeah what's your
worst bomb everybody has because I feel
like I was very like I couldn't believe
it
you like to press that yeah I was very
depressed I'm just like this is crazy
and I haven't kept reminding myself make
you funny I don't care you finds forget
about that people say well are you funny
bright light you don't matter it don't
matter you funny you funny
don't let this you know them people it's
like I can't tweet this one out the lab
yeah you know and people was giving me
advice out there to show like though
your site manages you know it's cool man
you know it's good it's good and like I
say once you feel it that one time it's
okay okay okay so ever happen again as I
okay I don't have some good show that
has no Kesha you know I know you know
there's the best teacher yeah man you
know once you don't feel it at one time
it's like okay I'm good Manning if you
come again I know how to deal with it
it'll come again yeah so it's like yeah
and there wasn't the only time that
wasn't no way it's been plenty of times
I don't when the room it's like quiet
and I haven't got what you know I say
Joe you know I don't to put that back
[Music]
but when somebody had told me before cuz
I used to be like hey this didn't work
here but it went good here you know it's
like don't take it away just some stuff
just you just gotta figure out what
works and that's like you know knowing
the crowds yes that's a big bang like
before you go up spots to who's in the
room like why do you know see was mmm
who's in here yeah what are they getting
laps one style today like yeah it's so
much see you so much we're standing up
that you have to learn mm-hmm you know
if there's an algorithm
oh man you gotta learn that stuff that's
process of everything I I'm going
through that process right now figuring
I'm still figuring that figuring
everything out right now so just like
you said with social media it's got to
be something you want to do that I want
to do because the work won't be working
you gotta want to end up you see people
with that our special you didn't see the
20 hours of failure behind that so
exactly it's straight up oh man oh my
god Jesus Christ goodness now especially
I look good I know they went through so
much just to get to that point yeah yeah
you're doing all the right things man so
like you you're building it up it seems
like you're you're giving the proper
attention to everything along the way
most of building it incrementally and
that's gonna be that strong foundation
visually everything will be here on the
same level
yeah you know I believe it yeah and I've
been a fan of you and your work I can
tell just from the amount of content
you're putting out the work ethic is
there and you're clearly talented but
then to look at it's literally it's a
portfolio of your body of work and maybe
be able to translate into doing films in
Africa yeah at 25 and then you get
recognized in Africa which you're just
like whoa neat yeah I couldn't believe
it
dude yo I couldn't believe that that was
like that was like the light of their
whole like trip like knowing people know
you in Africa what they say to you like
I was eating and the girl came up to me
she was like oh my god you you the boy
from everything I'm like wait a minute
I'm 16 and a half hours over the war
driving to my oh oh like what yeah this
is crazy you know and that was like
really spying it's like that's how I you
know I know I'm doing what I'm supposed
to be doing like well you could connect
with people across the world it's that's
that's it's like if you give up you
giving up on so many people it's like
damn like you don't do it like you me
you make people days you inspire people
help others chase their dreams you know
help people find out what they love to
do and that
that's the beauty of it like that's the
purpose of you know why I do what I do
so yeah man it's actually inspired yeah
it's not just by entertaining
yeah inspiring people man motivating
people because you know I do you know
even though like you say they don't see
the they just see the video they don't
know we go through on the other side you
notice the pressure that you own and how
you got to keep pushing through this
stuff to keep feeding the people you
know cuz it's not about you is really
now is about the people now it's crucial
listen to what they want give them more
yeah man so yeah I feel like in the and
you you're getting recognized in Africa
is shooting a film over there it's it
just seems like there are no boundaries
anymore in terms of entertainment and
that's where TV there come on TV almost
creates like a box it's stuck within a
box but the Internet has it's it's
infinite infinite it's beyond its I
guess you don't have to wait yes you
don't have to wait anymore you don't
have to like you can create your own
short films you can create your own
because is okay I can't remember who I
was watching but he is an interview I
can't think of actor name you know what
I was talking about you know people say
they want it do you want to be an actor
or you just want to act you know and it
you know like what do you want to do
okay you say you want to be actor okay
well create your own stuff then you be
actor you know I'm saying you want the
fame and you want to be on that level
okay it's like what do you want like
what is it that you want you know I'm
saying like as if II we can create a
short fam I we're acting but it's really
the fame it's really that big thing that
was chasing I think having cleared in
your goals is crucial so you know where
you're headed most definitely some
people like oh I want to I want to go to
Instagram get a million followers okay
why yeah and you want to do with the
most deathly we have a plan you have a
plan
yeah and once you find out this another
thing once you find that plan is like
everything a continue to grow as well
you actually write down your plan you
have to write the goes down oh alright
goes down like it's like now like the
platform that I have on the monster that
have the platform I have my Instagram is
for everything on the outside its
foreign movies it's for TV is for the
next-level stuff
it's for people to come to my shows you
know it's now it's gonna be just a
platform for me
you know it's what my support I want I
want my supporters to to be inspired but
me going to the next level I want them
to see that man I got I got it I want to
get to another level just the shoulder
of my how how God worked hmm you know
and he can do it if you believe but you
gotta believe he can do it you know and
having goals
I've heard people almost they'll
visualize them or they'll write them
down every day or they will actually
take time to write down their goals and
then just let them almost let them
almost firm it and come to life and you
can physically see them before they
actually happen most definitely because
I don't written out a few goals that
that has once I focused on to make it
came to pass hmm and it's it's like you
really have to be focused on what you
written I think success is focus is a
big part of being successful as well and
knowing what it is that you really want
to do and once you focus in on that and
you find purpose in that and you'd be
consisted in that eventually you're
gonna get what you what you written now
eventually it's gonna come to pass you
know I'm very spiritual cuz you know
that God promised us these things you
know we're written on a pay week okay
this this the goal is really I feel like
you know is this is she for God but we
still got to do our part as well you
know we just can't rely on God to do
everything you know people pray to these
things and they say hey we want you
doing you just sit back and just wait no
you gotta put in your work you got a
view out of you know once guy see you
doing that that's when you're gonna
elevate you he's gonna give you the
strength to like keep going do you put
timelines on your goals like I want to
know this by this like how right am I
goes I do them yearly so I'm gonna come
to these things this year so I don't I
don't know when it's going to happen I
just know in between this year these
goals gonna happen so what's what's on
the goal list for 2018
uh one of my biggest goals is be on TV
yeah and how specifically though like
you want to be a TV show you want to be
on a talk show like how do you do you
clear these goal yeah family the either
yeah this is a TV show it's a movie okay
that's acting yeah yeah active yeah yeah
mm-hmm is this your TV show or um just
TV I however however yeah I want to I
want to be on TV
2018 that's the goal that's my biggest
goal right okay did ya what I have I
have zero doubt you've you've been such
a thrill to have on this show yes it's
really been an honor to be able to
capture this moment I appreciate it man
I appreciate it I know you're very busy
and the fact you're willing to sit down
with the hot breath of Earth
oh yeah I enjoyed it yeah thanks Amy
before we get out of here man is there
anything else you want the world to know
um I would just say man hey find your
purpose in life man find out what it is
that you really want to do and stay
consistent with it and make sure it
brings a positive light to the world
yeah let him use you let him use you
dizzy banks makes me a hot breath my man
thanks bro
[Music]